con mucha solemnidad mensajes de
agradecimiento y lágrimas de miles y
miles de personas que se reunieron las
afueras del palacio de buckingham en la
avenida de moll en las afueras del
parlamento y por todas las calles del
centro de la capital británica donde
atravesó este cortejo fúnebre tan
solemne como impresionante en el que
participaron al menos 500 soldados de
diferentes regimientos e integrantes de
las fuerzas militares porque la reina
isabel también era la jefa de los
militares así que ha sido de mucha
solemnidad en este momento en el
westminster fold en el parlamento
británico que ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas avanza un servicio religioso de
tributo en el que se le rinde una vez
más un sentido homenaje a la reina
isabel segunda que falleció este jueves
a los 96 años éste tiene carácter
privado asisten los miembros de la
familia real liderados por el rey carlos
tercero la reina consorte los hermanos
del y el príncipe andrés eduardo y la
princesa anna la única hija mujer de la
reina los ocho nietos de isabel segunda
entre ellos harry y william también está
sara peter beatriz y jean y así que
todos asisten en este momento y en las
próximas horas entonces se abrirán ya
las puertas para que los miembros del
público puedan visitar el saber se hunda
en cámara ardiente
[Música]